I debated even bringing this story up
because it's a mean and nasty story and
so I'm not going to play the clip there
was a clip of the podcaster Patrick Bet
David making fun of Ron des santis and
Governor Dan santis is on the podcast
and people have been making fun of the
governor for wearing boots that seem
like they have a little lift in the heel
because Donald Trump is very tall Ronda
santis he's not short he's just a sort
of averaged height guy and but in
presidential elections usually the
taller candidate wins so some have
suggested that the governor like many
politicians before him is wearing some
kind of lift in his shoes the governor
and his team have denied this and so
this podcaster Patrick V David decided
to make fun of him and said hey man
what's the deal with the shoes these
shoes are weird you you got you're
wearing lifts here I'm going to buy you
a pair of Ferra and and Governor Dan
santis said I can't accept gifts you
know just shut it down as quickly as he
could why do do the shoes matter why do
people care that Governor Rhonda santis
the greatest governor in America right
now maybe the greatest governor in my
lifetime very serious man who's
accomplished a lot why do they care if
he puts lifts in his shoes
because people crave confidence this is
always true and if you put lifts in your
shoes it speaks to a sort of insecurity
even if it's a well-calculated
insecurity it's it still shows an
insecurity and so people don't like that
that there's nothing new about that
people are always attracted to confident
people but I think they're especially
attracted to confident people now and
the reason that they're especially
attracted to confident people now is
because we live in a time that is
pervaded by
skepticism where we're told that we
can't really know anything for certain
we're told
that long established facts well that's
just your opinion man we're taught that
basic philosophical premises or just you
know that's just what you think you
can't prove that how do you know you
don't know it's just your belief dude
come on man it's it's the big Labowski
well that's just your opinion man so in
this extremely skeptical age especially
in this extremely skeptical age any show
of confidence is very attractive I think
this helped Donald Trump who may have
been wrong a handful of times in his
life but he's never been in doubt I
think that's why people are attracted to
Trump I think it's why people are
attracted to AOC aoc's wrong about
almost everything but she's always so
confident about it and and someone
simply stating a
fact in a in a time of skepticism is is
really attractive and someone who
appears to have
insecurities even from the aesthetic
perspective is not going to do as well
and podcasters are going to make fun of
him like Patrick Bet David right now go
to bulletproof everyone.com use promo
code nolles we'd like to thank the
sponsor of today's show bulletproof
everyone because bulletproof everyone is
a premere American Body Armor
manufacturer and supplier designed and
built for everyday wear their unique
armor systems offer 25% more coverage
than standard armor while maintaining
flexibility and all day wearability
bulletproof everyone's ultra light armor
system is so light and thin you might
just forget you're wearing it your
safety and discretion is their top
concern unless someone puts their hands
on you no one will have any clue that
you're protected with bulletproof
everyone you are not a walking billboard
there are no visible logos and no flashy
designs they're comfortable tailor
clothing system goes above and beyond
adding additional security by keeping
you Incognito and under the radar work
or Play Bulletproof everyone has got the
perfect armor system to fit your
everyday lifestyle and everyday budget
right now our listeners can get 10% off
plus a free bulletproof backpack with
the purchase of any bulletproof clothing
just use code nles kwes at check out at
bulletproof everyone.com that is
bulletproof everyone.com promo code NOS
speaking of all that boring house
oversight the stuff they're uncovering
is good stuff it's good stuff even if
it's not going to persuade your average
voter on The Suite it will certainly
persuade the high information voters who
were listening to this particular
program but they got him you you've been
hearing from Joe Biden from the
beginning well where's the money show me
the money show me where the graft is
here here's where the graft is in July
of 2019 this according to the house
oversight committee this is three months
after Joe Biden announced he was running
for president hunter gets a quar million
doll loan from a Chinese business
associate
this is the wire that goes to Hunter
that used Joe Biden's Delaware home as
the beneficiary address so
it's I guess the consolation is they're
Crooks but and they're pretty good at it
but they make Elementary mistakes like
that Joe Biden's address is
on listed as the beneficiary address
well now we know neither Hunter nor Joe
Biden paid back that loan instead
Democrat donor and Hollywood lawyer
Kevin Morris acquired Hunter Biden stake
in Boh High Harvest rst which is one of
these sketchy China deals and then this
guy just assumed the debt for Hunter he
just assumed a quar million
dollars why why did he do that because
they were long-standing
friends childhood friends and he just
felt bad for poor old Hunter who he was
struggling with drugs and had a no they
actually only met in 201 19 at a
political fundraiser at a political
fundraiser for Joe Biden's
campaign so they meet at this political
fund rais say oh hey you're a Joe
Biden's son right cool how can I bribe
you how how can oh cool I can assume
this loan that was never going to be
paid back anyway from your crooked
counterparts in China okay
great so house overide asks why is a
Democrat donor taking on Hunter's China
debt raises serious ethical questions
yeah of course I love this stuff I
encourage James comr and the house
oversight committee to keep digging it
up I I like to be able to have proof
when people make silly claims like there
is no evidence that Joe Biden took
bribes or anything like that I I like to
be able to refute
that it's not going to matter people
know Joe Biden just like people know
Donald Trump people know Joe Biden they
know that he is a simpering backs
slapping empty suit of a politician they
know he's dirty they know he takes
bribes they know it doesn't matter
just like people know Donald Trump he
can be nasty sometimes he says mean
things he he is loose with his language
he's unpredictable politically
yeah yeah we all know
that this is why it's it's not going to
work the the candidates who are running
against Trump in the primary and they
they keep pointing out all the problems
with
Trump that his opponents pointed out in
2016 but we know him he's he's one of
the most famous men in the world okay
the guy's been famous since the 80s and
then he was the president of the United
States he was the star of a of a major
Network TV show for 12 years or
something or more then he was the
president yeah we know we know him and
We Know Joe Biden and none of this is
going to make a
difference when I see these these weak
attacks on Trump this did you see Donald
Trump misspoke this man he's not the
same man as 20 what are you talking he
is exactly the same man he also misspoke
in 2016 and no one cares
there some people care but they already
don't like
him did you see Joe Biden took a bribe
yeah
uh-huh I did I did see that that's not
going to matter that's not what's going
to move the needle what's really going
to move the needle in this election as
far as I'm concerned is how voter ID
ballot harvesting and mailin ballots are
are orchestrated in The crucial swing
States now I think that's going to be
the big difference and I think the
candidates are basically already set man
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hey hey before you go ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles podcast
we'll see you next time